[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines voici le
programme de ce 3 janvier
[Musique]
baisse de la croissance inflation
galopante chômage qui repart en hausse
2023 s'annonce compliqué sur le plan
économique quels sont les perspectives
pour l'année qui débute comment les
entreprises abordent-elles ses premiers
mois nous poser la question à nos
invités ils nous en profiterons
également pour faire un petit point sur
la fiscalité de cette année on en a
parlé et on a parlé du sport hier mais
l'année 2023 sera aussi culturelle
quelles sont les grands événements
prévus sur le territoire en matière de
culture les dates à ne pas rater dans
cette édition et puis zoom sur
raconte-moi ta vie un dispositif auquel
participe trois établissements de
l'académie de Versailles l'objectif pour
les jeunes participants parler de leur
histoire personnelle au travers
d'ateliers d'écriture reportage au lycée
Jacques Vaucanson des Mureaux
et ce sera dans notre partie dédiée à la
culture en deuxième et demi heure de ce
7 8 avec également au programme des
invités qui nous ont rejoints en plateau
Margot l'Allier bonsoir vous êtes la
directrice du pôle médiation action
culturelle et publique au CMBV c'est le
Centre de Musique Baroque de Versailles
et le cmbb c'est ce dont on va parler ce
soir propose depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois quelques années maintenant les
explodcasts le troisième numéro est
sorti en novembre dernier on parle
d'expérience sonore et visuelle quel est
le concept des exploits de cast alors un
exploit de casse c'est une exposition
virtuelle sur un site internet
interactif et un podcast en coproduction
avec France Musique et la Comédie
Française et donc le troisième numéro je
le disais qui est consacré à la région
en musique que la fête commence est
sortie en novembre on va le présenter
tout à l'heure et parler aussi de
l'actualité plus générale du cmbv1 au
début de cette année
2023 avec nous également thêta bonsoir
artiste musical originaire de
Montfort-l'Amaury c'est bien ça dans les
aujourd'hui on fera votre connaissance
tout à l'heure et on parlera de ce
premier projet musical en solo qui est
sorti en novembre c'est born tooloz born
Toulouse voilà et pardon pour l'accent
anglais et c'est sorti donc en novembre
alors pour présenter un petit peu votre
univers vous vous définissez comme une
artiste dark pop électro pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne vous connaissent
pas qu'est-ce que c'est concrètement cet
univers c'est de la pop en fait c'est
des mélodies qui sont très pop qui sont
posées sur une production donc les
arrangements musicaux derrière qui est
très destructuré et très électronique
dans les influences on aura l'occasion
de le voir avec un univers
dark pop d'ailleurs si on prend juste le
Dark pop il y a des influences comme
Billie eilish par exemple
car Rosalia ou escape weeks aussi donc
la nouveauté avec vous c'est que il y a
le côté électro aussi on associe il y a
des teintes électro qui vont de la
techno aux années 80 aussi parfois dans
les influences on en dira un peu plus
tout à l'heure la suite également des
informations avec les informations du
jour ce sera avec vous dans un instant
Gabriel Gontier bonsoir on parlera
notamment du Pass Navigo également de
Carlo livre le député des Yvelines qui a
publié une vidéo assez originale en ce
début d'année 2020
on en parlera à tout à l'heure et aussi
à suivre ce mardi notre deuxième épisode
de nos rétros de 2022 nous nous
rappellerons des événements qui se sont
produits qui sont déroulés en avril et
juin dernier dans le département et puis
comme chaque mardi également l'astuce de
notre chef yvelinois pour briller en
cuisine mais avant tout cela on regarde
la météo de demain
de la pluie au menu de votre journée de
mercredi sur l'ensemble du département
demain matin il fera 10 degrés à
Rambouillet 11 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles 12 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie la pluie également dans
de la partie dans l'après-midi côté
température prévoyez 13 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan 12 degrés du côté
de Versailles et Rambouillet ce mercredi
à 4 janvier c'est la saint Odilon
et je le dise à les informations du jour
avec vous Gabriel Gontier information de
ce mardi 3 janvier on débute avec notre
image du jour oui une image du jour
sportive car depuis le 31 décembre le
Dakar 2023 a lancé et lancer c'est la
45e édition Grégory cette année alors
parmi les pilotes de Yvelines
Jean-Pierre Garcin copilote du chinois
Guilloud zen actuellement à la 35e place
automobile pour l'instant loin de ses
objectifs de Top 10 l'autre yvelinois
c'est Jean-Pierre strugo qui a la 41e
place avec son coéquipier Christophe
Crespo il fête cette année son 31ème
Dakar à 76 ans et après deux étapes et
589 km aujourd'hui c'est une étape de
447 km qui attendait les sportifs étape
raccourci pour cause de mauvaises
conditions climatiques les résultats
devraient arriver dans les prochaines
minutes Grégory
4 2023 avec attention alors eux n'ont
pas repris la route mais le chemin de
l'école plus de 300000 élèves des
Yvelines aujourd'hui après deux semaines
et un jour c'est important de le
préciser de vacances les écoliers sont
de retour à l'école alors si les enfants
ont gagné un jour de congés pour les
parents en revanche il fallait parfois
trouver un mode de garde cette décision
a été justifiée par PAP Andy le ministre
de l'éducation nationale par un souci de
sécurité routière ce qui a évité à
certains de prendre la route un
lendemain de soirée une information qui
concerne notre porte-monnaie directement
oui c'est notre chiffre du du jour si
vous habitez à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
sachez que votre taxe foncière est moins
élevé que celle dans les villes voisines
avec un taux de
21,55%, alors depuis 12 ans à
Saint-Germain les taux de taxe local
n'ont pas augmenté dans cette ville là
où c'était pourtant importante dans les
Yvelines l'année dernière accentuer par
la mise en place d'un niveau de taxe
foncière prélevé par la communauté des
communes
dans cette édition avec le le directeur
départemental des finances publiques des
Yvelines qui viendra nous parler
notamment de ce qui a changé au premier
janvier 2023 une conséquence de plus sur
l'inflation c'est aussi le coût le coup
de l'eau potable qui va être plus élevé
exactement les habitants de la
Communauté
Urbaine Grand Paris scène et Oise vont
devoir faire face à une hausse de la
redevance communautaire de l'eau potable
de 0,30 centimes par mètre cube en
moyenne alors l'indice de prix à la
consommation bandit de 5,68% sur les 12
mois de référence vous parliez tout à
l'heure aussi de la hausse d'un prix
d'un abonnement c'est celui alors vous
en parler hier vous en parliez hier
pardon la hausse du prix de l'abonnement
du passe Navigo il y a une mauvaise
surprise pour de nombreux usagers qui
ont rencontré des difficultés
aujourd'hui lors du rechargement
justement de cette carte de transport
tout à fait Grégory le Pass Navigo fait
encore parler de lui à la suite d'un
problème technique certains voyageurs
ont été prélevés plusieurs fois ce qui
est assez embêtant
Île-de-France mobilité a indiqué que les
paiements superflus seraient remboursés
automatiquement rapidement bon on
l'espère effectivement et on termine en
chanson en musique oui on termine avec
une vidéo qui permettez-moi l'expression
a fait le buzz sur Twitter celle de
l'ancien maire de Poissy car l'olive
alors pour la nouvelle année le député a
le nouveau député Renaissance pardon a
publié une chanson parodique intitulée
Les députés où il se met en scène en
chanson la vidéo récolte déjà près de
160 000 vues je vous propose qu'on
écoute un extrait
au Parlement on y passera beaucoup de
temps histoire de faire voter les lois
et parfois jusqu'au bout de la nuit on
oubliera d'aller au lit c'est arrivé un
paquet de foire
moins une chanson atteint du monde mais
c'est moi qu'on le puit que l'on puisse
dire les députés vont avoir du travail
hein cette année tout à fait notamment
avec la réforme des retraites on en a
beaucoup entendu parler alors ce matin
la première ministre Elisabeth borne a
assuré au micro de nos confrères de
France Info que le gouvernement n'irait
pas au-delà des 43 années de cotisations
réforme des retraites merci Gabriel pour
toutes ces informations et si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un
fait d'actualité qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à le dire sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
toute cette semaine TV 78 se remémore
les événements marquants de l'année
dernière dans les Yvelines deuxième
rétrospective ce soir avec les
événements d'avril à juin 2022 c'est
avec Nicolas dandry et vous et Gabriel
Gontier et le premier avril la salle du
Jeu de Paume de Versailles où vos portes
au public après une période de
rénovation ce site historique symbolique
de la Révolution française et berceau de
la République et la République française
avait un rendez-vous important le 10 et
23 avril 2022 face à la candidate du
rassemblement national Emmanuel Macron
est réélu en recueillant 58% des voix
dans les Yvelines le président de la
République devant largement Marine Le
Pen avec 71% des suffrages à noter
l'important taux d'abstention qui
atteint des niveaux historiques
l'histoire s'écrit aussi au FC
Versailles après une saison pleine les
footballeurs Versailles ont validé leur
montée en National à Saint-Malo c'est
une première pour le club quelques
semaines plus tard Versailles sera sacré
champion de National 2 après leur
victoire 1 à 0 face à Plabennec autre
événement sportif direction le vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
avec un tournoi international de Andy
tennis de table le Skype French Open
environ 380 plongistes venus de 33 pays
ont pu concourir durant 4 jours du 5 au
8 mai l'événement se déroulait aux
Clayes-sous-Bois le geek-up festival à
rassemblé des personnages de mangas du
monde médiéval ou encore des sorciers la
magie de la nature au zoo de Thoiry
plusieurs naissances au sein du parc
animalier Kat louveteaux 7 bébés coyote
et huit renardeaux une année
exceptionnelle qui permet de préserver
des espèces parfois menacées au chapitre
éducation le lycée franco-allemand de
Buc fait pot neuve des nouvelles salles
d'enseignement la reconstruction du
gymnase ou encore une toiture en forme
de parasol pour récupérer l'eau de pluie
des travaux qui permettent d'augmenter
les capacités d'accueil des élèves le le
mois de juin a été marqué par le
troisième tour des présidentielles les
élections législatives dans les Yvelines
quatre nouveaux députés ont été élus car
l'olive et Charles Rodwell pour la
majorité présidentielle Benjamin Lucas
et William Martinet ont fait basculer
respectivement la 8e et la 11e
circonscription à gauche ces deux
parlementaires siègent dans le groupe de
la nupes les Yvelines à l'honneur au
sein du Palais Bourbon d'abord la
députée de la dixième circonscription
des Yvelines Aurore Bergé est élu
présidente du groupe parlementaire
Renaissance et Yaël Brown privé est élu
par les 577 députés de l'hémicycle
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale une
élection particulière pour livelinoise
qui devient la première femme à occuper
cette fonction dans l'histoire politique
française
baisse de la croissance inflation
galopante chômage qui repart en hausse
l'année 2023 s'annonce compliqué sur le
plan économique alors quels sont les
perspectives pour cette année comment
les entreprises également à bordel c'est
premiers mois on va poser la question à
nos invités qui nous ont rejoint autour
de la table Véronique Jérôme bonsoir
bonsoir Polito économiste vous êtes
également la fondatrice des d'élections
SCOP en quelques mots élections scope
avec Bruno Jérôme on est un site qui
fait de l'analyse politiqueo-économique
des élections c'est à dire qu'on essaie
d'expliquer le comportement des
électeurs qui sont aussi des
consommateurs et des contribuables et
avec cette observation on peut
comprendre leur comportement et cerise
sur le gâteau prévoir les élections nous
voir aussi le lien économie politique
qui peut exister également à Zakaria
Hardy président du Medef 78 qui était
avec nous bonsoir bonsoir on va voir
avec vous aussi quel état d'esprit dans
quel état d'esprit les chefs
d'entreprise abordent cette nouvelle
année en face de vous il y a également
Philippe Dufresnoy bonsoir qui est le
directeur de la Direction départementale
des finances publiques des on fera un
petit point fiscal et voir ce qui change
aussi en ce 1er janvier du côté de la
fiscalité des particuliers mais aussi
des entreprises et je pense que ça va
vous intéresser directement Zacharie
Hardy et nous a rejoint également en
plateau Patrice carmouz directeur de
l'information tv78 bonsoir bonsoir
Patrice alors premier chiffre avec cette
croissance inquiéter à 1% en tout cas le
gouvernement qui table sur une
croissance de 1% en 2023 même si le
gouverneur de la Banque de France à
François Villeroy de Gallo est encore
plus pessimiste il parle d'une
croissance de moins de 1%
0,3% c'est c'est plus ça c'est plus
cette croissance là Véronique Jérôme qui
est qui est avancé qui est à prévoir sur
cette année 2023 je voudrais pas jouer
les Madame Irma parce que finalement la
matière on ne peut pas donner avec
certitude un chiffre en la matière il y
a un consensus des économistes qui
donnent 0,1% la Banque de France donnait
03 Emmanuel Macron lui-même un temps à
donner plutôt une fourchette de 0,4 à
0,7
20% semble à l'heure où l'on parle par
trop optimiste mais en même temps il a
servi à faire les prévisions pour le
budget 2023 donc ça signifie que là on
peut avoir un problème si la croissance
ne s'avère pas aussi forte que prévu ça
signifie que beaucoup des éléments qui
constituent un peu ceple sur lequel
repose la croissance vont s'écrouler on
pourrait alors le Conseil
constitutionnel à rejeter la question de
un sincérité du budget au motif que ces
chiffres bon on fait avec ce que l'on a
aussi au moment où on fait le budget on
prend les les éléments qui sont à
disposition si on regarde 2022 on a deux
et demi pour cent de croissance en
France donc on peut se dire que 1% c'est
pas aussi irréaliste qui peut le
paraître 2021 voilà mais après bon il y
a des rattrapages qui se sont perrés
2021 et peut-être aussi un élément qui
qui entre les deux comptes et qui qui
donne encore de de l'oxygène à
l'économie maintenant le gros sujet
c'est la croissance est centrale parce
que quand on a de la croissance on n'est
pas obligé d'augmenter les impôts on a
des éléments l'assiette fiscale
s'élargit quand on a de la croissance on
a moins d'occasion d'intervention pour
quand il n'a pas de croissance qui est
un peu le cas quand même actuellement on
va avoir des obligations d'intervention
sur l'économie alors est-ce que il y
aura une autre question à laquelle on ne
pourra pas répondre complètement ce soir
mais est-ce que c'est à l'État
d'intervenir systématiquement et de
d'user de la dépense publique pour
colmater les brèches ou est-ce qu'on
peut faire un peu parfois confiance au
marché et laisser un peu l'offre
s'exprimer avec un peu moins de
contrainte et là on peut avoir voilà
alors pour l'instant l'état elle est
intervient il intervient il a même
relancé un peu la machine sur le plan
des boucliers donc là on a des des
engagements qui sont pris parce que je
pense que vous êtes mieux placé que moi
pour le dire l'économie en a besoin mais
à la fois les collectivités locales les
entreprises et les consommateurs on leur
promet de les protéger contre
l'inflation je dirais simplement deux
mots cette protection contre l'inflation
elle passe aussi par une politique
monétaire que l'on dit restrictive c'est
à dire que les banques centrales la fête
Racer fédérale et la Banque centrale
européenne augmente leur taux d'intérêt
et l'argent magique ce sera bientôt
terminé les taux d'intérêt négatives ce
sera bientôt terminé en augmentant les
taux d'intérêt
fait une contraction de la masse
monétaire et ça signifie que le crédit
sera plus compliqué à distribuer et on
en espère finalement un ralentissement
de l'inflation si c'est efficace ça peut
être une solution et à mi 2023 les
choses repartent dans le bon sens si ce
n'est pas efficace le problème c'est que
ça peut produire un effet inverse ça
peut ne pas tuer l'inflation et si
l'inflation perdure on risque d'avoir
des difficultés sur la production et à
terme sur le chômage c'est d'avoir de
l'inflation et la récession le chômage
repartait à la hausse le chômage repart
un peu et ça c'est vraiment une variable
qui est sensible à laquelle les acteurs
sont sensibles mais on a et on a le
chômage tout dépend là encore de la
façon dont on le mesure est-ce qu'on
prend au sens du BIT ou est-ce qu'on le
prend au sens des demandeurs d'emploi et
quelle catégorie catégorie A ou on va
jusqu'à ABCDE et là on a une vision qui
est un peu un peu plus proche du terrain
peut-être parce que sur le terrain le
ressenti et pas conforme à ce que donne
à voir le chiffre des catégories parce
que sur le terrain il y a un peu de tout
aussi on optimiste
ça marche pas il c'est-à-dire
l'inflation plus le chômage si
l'économie est capable de donner un coup
de pied au niveau de la piscine ce n'est
capable de donner un coup de pied au
fond de la piscine et de repartir et
bien ça redémarrera mais là on va
compter sur des locomotives sur les
États-Unis l'Europe et la Chine et là on
sait que ces trois pays trois catégories
ont des difficultés la Chine c'est le
zéro covidique du Zéro covid est-ce que
finalement ils ont sorte est-ce qu'ils
retrouvent les les les éléments de
croissance qu'ils avaient précédemment
les États-Unis pour l'instant leur
premier pas la récession mais peut-être
et en Europe il y a moitié des pays
européens à qui on promet le récession
et en particulier l'Allemagne là on a un
vrai problème c'est que l'Allemagne
n'est plus le moteur comme elle était
précédemment croissance au ralenti on a
parlé aussi d'inflation à ce chiffre qui
était sorti en novembre 6,2 %
d'augmentation de des prêts à la
consommation sur un an et le mise de
l'économie un Bruno Le Maire elle a bien
précisé que le pic n'avait pas été
encore atteint de cette inflation du
coup Zakaria Hardy je me tend vers vous
les chefs d'entreprise dans quel état
d'esprit abordent-ils cette nouvelle
année on imagine avec de l'inquiét
est-ce que on voit aussi le vert
peut-être à moitié plein je ne sais pas
du côté des chefs d'entreprise non mais
c'est vrai avec pas mal d'inquiétudes
parce que le premier trimestre je dirais
il y a focus sur sur le coup d'énergie
et le coup d'énergie aujourd'hui
bouleverse pas mal la donne pour les
entreprises
grève terriblement la trésorerie puisque
par exemple une entreprise qui payait
une facture de 400000 euros annuel
d'électricité et les passer à 2 millions
d'euros 2 millions d'euros le résultat
qui était d'un million d'euros
aujourd'hui l'entreprise
structurellement perd un million donc si
vous le bouclier tarifaire le bouclier
tarifaire ne représente que 20% du coût
total de l'augmentation donc quand vous
avez le coût qui a été multiplié par 5
et bien il y a quatre fois le prix qui
reste à payer et donc sur le sujet
d'ailleurs la première ministre ce matin
Elisabeth borne a annoncé que les
entreprises en difficulté dont les
boulangers qui sont coucher de plein
fouet par l'augmentation des prix
pourront demander à un report de
paiement de leur impôts et de leur
cotisations sociales pour soulager leur
trésorerie quand vous entendez une telle
annonce ce matin comment comment vous
réagissez est-ce que vous pensez que ça
peut aller dans le bon sens vous
attendez de voir aussi le concret suite
à cette annonce dans le bon sens mais
que fait-on en fait on décale la
problématique
si l'inflation continue
et si les coups de bélier de cette de
coût de l'énergie continue et bien le
problème sera reporté et on sera en face
du mur le moment où il faudra rembourser
ou payer ses dettes
quel est votre souhait alors c'est le
souhait très simple nous souhaitons que
le gouvernement négocie avec l'Europe
justement se désaccouplage de la France
par rapport au mécanisme de calculs de
prix d'énergie c'est fixé sur le prix du
basé sur le prix du gaz et en fait nous
nos produisons en fait le prix que nous
payons aujourd'hui ne correspond pas au
prix de production de l'énergie en
France et c'est totalement aberrant donc
aujourd'hui on a un avantage qui est
l'électricité qui est produite par le
nucléaire nous permet d'avoir des coûts
compétitifs même si effectivement à
terme si le prix du gaz baisse ça
pourrait éventuellement amener à une
baisse du coût d'énergie mais ce que
nous souhaitons nous c'est effectivement
basé nos coûts basé notre stratégie sur
un coup qui soit relativement stable sur
les coûts de production liés au
nucléaire et ça nous permet d'avoir une
visibilité et une maîtrise de nos coûts
d'énergie il y a le gouvernement mais le
fournisseur d'énergie aussi absolument
aujourd'hui c'est les énergéticiens
fondent d'anticipation c'est à dire
qu'il maintiennent des prix très élevés
ont prévisions d'une réaction éventuelle
notamment de la Russie qui va leur
provoquer des coûts supplémentaires à
l'avenir et donc il ne font pas profiter
les entreprises et les clients de la
baisse des coûts de l'énergie parce que
quand même il faut le savoir c'est que
le coût de l'énergie il est en train de
baisser actuellement notamment pour les
grands comptes et aujourd'hui les petits
consommateurs qui sont notamment les
boulangers les petites PME etc etc ne
bénéficient pas de ce de cette baisse et
ce que souhaitons que justement que le
générique les énergéticiens baissent
leur coût et que ça soit rapide que ça
soit pas dans la durée voilà et que la
situation des entreprises dans les
Yvelines elle est très différente selon
je parle plutôt des petites et moyennes
entreprises et quelle était là
actuellement les états d'esprit à l'état
d'esprit il est un peu
donc c'est c'est vraiment nous sommes
tous sur la même barque et et vraiment
une une vraie inquiétude une vraie
souffrance parce que
il y en a beaucoup qui effectivement qui
font passer des messages d'espoir ça va
baisser ça va baisser je pense
sincèrement qui va falloir s'habituer à
ce que le coût de la vie soit plus cher
qu'avant ça ne rebaissera pas et ça ne
redeviendra pas comme avant maintenant
comment l'anticiper il faut qu'on puisse
avoir de la visibilité et de la
stabilité dans les dans les prix
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas
notamment pour l'énergie et là vraiment
nous souhaitons que le gouvernement
puisse puisse faire quelque chose
se désaccouplage que nous appelons de
tout nos vœux il faut qu'il y arrive
mais surtout le plus rapidement possible
avant qu'il soit trop tard est-ce que
malgré ce contexte vous allez les
entreprises vont quand même investir en
2023 donc là vous parlez de quelque
chose qui est un peu compliqué en ce
moment
vous l'avez dit le coup du crédit
devient de plus en plus cher les
conditions se durcissent donc là
l'argent pour avoir accès à l'argent à
l'emprunt ça devient très difficile donc
la première impact c'est que les
investissements sont en train de se
contracter ce contrat est surtout les
entreprises qui disposent de plusieurs
sites notamment à l'international sont
en train de revoir comment ils vont
faire pour distribuer ou pour réorienter
leur production sur des zones où le coût
d'énergie est plus clément entre
guillemets voilà Véronique giron
peut-être avant qu'on fasse un point
aussi fiscal sur cette année 2023 je
crois que ce que vous dites vous parlez
d'or parce que finalement ça signifie
qu'il y a une efficacité marginale du
capital qui qui se qui deviennent
contraintes les entreprises ne prendront
d'investissement que ceux qui sont
encore rentables et égard au taux
d'intérêt qui augmente donc il y a de
moins en moins d'investissements qui
vont être réalisés parce qu'ils certains
seront pas efficaces eu simplement mise
en perspective avec le taux d'intérêt
qu'il faut prendre en considération et
donc ça c'est un qui peut expliquer
aussi ce que l'on constate en France
parce que on a aussi un gros handicap
c'est qu'on est un pays qui se
désindustrialise quand on fait le
rapport de le poids d'industrie dans le
PIB c'est 13% en français c'est 26% en
Allemagne c'est même 16% en Espagne qui
croirait que qui aurait cru il y a
quelques années encore finalement que
enfin on va pas faire on va souffrir de
de de de d'une comparaison avec
l'Espagne mais qui pouvait croire que la
France laisserait d'y passer comme ça
dans dans la zone dans la zone euro et
dans le dans l'Union européenne donc on
a un souci on a un pays qui se
désindustrialisent et cette faiblesse
est un élément qui qui va qui va
impacter tous les tous les secteurs
finalement ce qui va permettre de
retrouver de la croissance il nous reste
quoi il nous reste l'aéronautique le
luxe le tourisme mais voilà c'est on
avait quelques années déjà parlé de la
France ce pays des services il prend des
services et l'innovation mais là
l'innovation là encore on va pas la
décréter il faut avoir des éléments des
incitations il faut que les chefs
d'entreprise croient l'innovation et
c'est tout à fait rien votre remarque
Patrice parce que finalement
il faut les déboucher parce que sinon on
va arriver à une situation où le secteur
privé va se trouver dépendant du secteur
public on a une Schumpeter parler de
cette de cette de cette contrainte
fiscale finalement l'État qui pourrait
aider le secteur privé va dépenser et
pour dépenser il est obligé d'augmenter
les impôts en augmentant les impôts il
aggrave la situation des entreprises et
on a ce cirque ce cycle ce cycle et ce
cercle infernal disait Schumpeter la
solution c'est l'innovation l'innovation
elle se décrète pas il faut avoir des
éléments juste le temps de très
rapidement avant qu'on passe à fiscalité
Zakaria vous parlez de l'investissement
l'emploi est-ce que les règles nouvelles
qui ont été faites pour l'emploi qui
permettent d'avoir plus de souplesse
permettent quand même dans une situation
difficile aux entreprises de d'engager
des personnes même si c'est difficile de
trouver des personnes correspondant aux
emplois que que vous souhaitez mais
c'est vrai malgré ses règles là c'est
vrai ça ça donne des perspectives le
souci c'est que l'offre aujourd'hui
n'est pas on adéquation avec la demande
et c'est que aujourd'hui
il est urgent qu'on puisse organiser le
circuit de formation pour transformer
les compétences et les amener vers les
vrais besoins qu'on a aujourd'hui au
sein des entreprises mais bon il y a
beaucoup d'offres d'emploi qui restent
sans voilà aujourd'hui on est on estime
entre 500 et 600 000 offres d'emploi qui
n'est pas satisfaite en France c'est le
fiscalité avec notre invité également
autour de cette étape c'est Philippe
Dufresnoy je rappelle vous êtes à la
tête de la Direction départementale des
finances publiques des Yvelines on va
parler de fiscalité pour les
particuliers aussi pour les pour les
entreprises déjà un petit bilan sur
l'année 2022 quel est-il pour les défis
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on c'est
comme ça qu'on dit c'est l'acronyme de
direction départementale des finances
publiques les finances publiques se sont
relativement bien portés dans le
département les recettes étaient assez
bonnes c'est paradoxal mais nous
regardons dans le rétroviseur il y avait
de la croissance pour les particuliers
ça a été une année où beaucoup de
d'impôts ont été supprimés la
contribution autovisuelle qui est
l'ancienne redevance la taxe
d'habitation pour les entreprises il y a
eu une baisse des impôts de production
et c'est tendance se poursuivre
j'ajouterai que la fiscalité c'est aussi
une ressource pour aider les entreprises
et dès 2022 des dispositifs d'aide avait
été mis en place face à l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie et ceci se
poursuit également en 2023 et du coup
des aides qui se poursuivent peut-être
pour les entreprises si on fait le point
sur les particuliers on va faire réagiri
sur les aides pour les pour les
entreprises quelles sont les aides
justement pour faire face à cette
inflation on a parlé d'inflation
dans cette édition pour les particuliers
on parle de cette de cette indemnité
carburant notamment ce début d'année
c'est le mot qui revient souvent il y a
le bouclier de tarifaire qui est
prolongé mais qui sera à 15% de garantie
au lieu de 4 et puis l'indemnités
carburant entre en application à partir
du 16 janvier c'est une indemnité basée
sur un revenu fiscal de référence comme
on dit qui représente pour une personne
seule 1341 euros par mois donc c'est
relativement bas ce sont les cinq
premiers des cils en termes techniques
ça représenterait autour de 250 000
personnes dans les Yvelines c'est une
approximation ça représentera 100 euros
par véhicule les conditions sont assez
simples il faut aller sur son site
impôts gouv dans son espace particulier
donner son numéro de contribua donner
son numéro d'immatriculation ou C
numéros si on est deux à conduire dans
le foyer on peut avoir deux indemnités
elle est de 100 euros et il faut
s'engager sur l'honneur à utiliser son
véhicule pour des raisons
professionnelles elle est ciblées sur
les gens qui travaillent et l'indemnité
devrait être versée à condition qu'on
est donné son RIB c'est une condition
toute bête dans les 8 10 jours qui
suivent la démarche si on a du mal à
utiliser Internet parce que ça peut
arriver il y a une vingtaine d'espaces
francs services dans le département et
puis il y a 8 centres des finances
publiques mais notre site est assez
simple et je pense que les gens y
arriveront Philippe Dufresnoy parler de
l'aide pour les entreprises elle se
ressent du côté des chefs d'entreprise
cette aide fiscale
fiscal
d'abord le dispositif est très complexe
donc il faut vraiment déréchir le
terrain pour pouvoir y accéder en
réalité notre position à nous c'est de
dire ce fameux quoi qu'il en coûte il va
falloir qu'ils cesse pourquoi parce que
ce quoi qu'il en coûte il a toujours une
conséquence c'est une politique fiscale
dure cette politique fiscale de
prélèvement qui va se traduire
certainement sur une fiscalité plus
importante sur les entreprises ça va
grever la compétitivité de nos
entreprises pour l'instant
magique n'existe pas
le discours officiel c'est pas de vous
c'est pas seulement le discours c'est la
loi la loi de finance 2023 baisse les
impôts de production alors il est vrai
que ce décès en deux étapes au lieu
d'une tout à fait ça baisse quand même
ça prolonge une baisse intérieure le
taux d'impôt sur les sociétés avait
baissé l'an dernier le régime des
petites entreprises en matière de
taxation en impôt sur les sociétés a été
améliorées pour 2023 tout ça on compose
plutôt un paysage de stabilité voire
d'allègement fiscal
et par ailleurs le dispositif des aides
il est compliqué mais parce qu'on cible
sur les différentes populations et il y
a une personne qui s'appelle la
conseillère départementale à la sortie
de crise dans le département on peut la
contacter au téléphone ou sur Internet
il est bon de s'adresser à elle elle
peut ensuite alors c'est le 0806 00
ce type c'est marqué ici si vous
souhaitez le noter l'adresse mail est
également très pratique
il faut reconnaître qu'il y a de
nombreuses aides il y a des chèques de
différents types il y a un bouclier un
amortisseur un guichet donc en matière
énergétique il y a trois dispositifs qui
jouent les uns après les autres selon le
type d'entreprises ça mérite un peu de
temps mais on est là pour aider alors ce
qui est important aussi c'est les
nouveautés fiscales en ce début d'année
203 pareil on va parler des nouveautés
pour les particuliers les entreprises
pour terminer la première pour les
particuliers celle qui revient souvent
c'est de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation c'est une suppression qui
avait débuté en 2018 et cette année en
2003 plus aucun français va payer cette
taxe d'habitation c'est la taxe
d'habitation principale qui achève sa
disparition en 2023 elle subsiste la
taxe d'habitation pour le résidence
secondaire il faut en avoir conscience
et donc la taxe d'habitation ne sera
supprimée que pour ceux qui habitent
dans leur résidence principale vous avez
une résidence secondaire vous continuez
à payer la taxe d'habitation les autres
nouveautés à retenir pour les
particuliers alors pour les particuliers
il y a un niveau assez significatif
c'est l'indexation du barème de l'impôt
sur le revenu sur l'inflation qui est un
signe de réalisme économique ce qui n'a
pas toujours été le cas il y a eu des
années entre 2011 et 2014 où la
désindexation du barème représentait une
augmentation d'impôts en creux là le
barème est indexé l'inflation est prise
en compte de même que les valeurs
locatives des bases qui servent à
asseoir la taxe foncière sont indexées
sur l'inflation donc il y a une volonté
de réalisme économique dans la loi de
finances 2023 et on termine avec les
entreprises alors c'est aussi une
suppression qui est progressive qui
avait intervenir en 2023 et 2024 c'est
la CVAE c'est cette contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée des des entreprises ça
débute cette année la suppression ça se
progressive c'est un deuxième train de 5
milliards il y aura un troisième train
de 5 milliards ce qui fera une vingtaine
de milliards on peut soutenir sur le
plan de la comparaison que d'autres
impôts devraient être supprimés la C3S
mais en tout cas il y a des gestes très
tangibles qui sont dans le budget et qui
sont lancés comme une bouée de soutien
aux entreprises ça ce sont des aides qui
certes sont diffuses mais qui finissent
quand même par représenter un facteur de
compétitivité Patrice juste un bout
parce que on parlait justement des
difficultés des autres avec la facture
énergétique et on disait juste avant il
y a combien de boulanger dans les
Yvelines et combien vous ont contacté
alors il y a 390 boulangers on a
peut-être mal compté mais c'est l'ordre
d'idée et pour l'instant nous avons été
contactés par 5 entreprises de
boulangerie donc on peut penser qu'il
faut il faut venir nous voir le Premier
ministre a annoncé ce matin qu'il
fallait être bienveillant nos services
sont prêts à donner des plans de
règlement nous pouvons aménager des
plans de règlement jusqu'à 4 ans ce qui
n'est pas négligeable donc c'est une
disposition qui est en trésorerie est
intéressante ne résout pas tout mais ça
permet de voir venir et ça a bien marché
pendant la crise précédente celle de la
covid on va relayer en tout cas le
numéro que vous avez de la conseillère
de sortie de crise c'est de 0,806
245 et l'adresse internet c'est code
défi
ccsef@dfips
78.1 finances avec un s.gouv.fr je pense
qu'une incrustation sera bonne on va le
mettre sur le on va le mettre sur le
site
vous la connaissez déjà bien merci à
vous quatre je le rappelle Philippe
Dufresnoy à la directeur de la Direction
départementale des finances publiques
des Yvelines également Véronique Jérôme
qui était avec nous économiste et je le
rappelle cofondatrice de élections SCOP
et Zacharie Hardy président du Medef 78
merci également à Patrice carmouz
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
directeur de l'information de TV 78
allez à présent un peu de culture dans
le 7 8
[Musique]
et alors que l'année 2023 débute quelles
sont les événements culturels à ne pas
manquer ni de la lecture moi Molière
également des rendez-vous musicaux
Mathilde Franco a fait le point sur tous
ces rendez-vous elle parle aussi des
festivals regardez cette année 2023
commence par les nuits de la lecture sur
le thème de la peur au programme lecture
horrifique et jeux d'ambiance les
médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous propose
plusieurs rendez-vous compte à frémir à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux s'amuser à avoir
peur à Guyancourt ou encore le swing des
tout-petits à Maurepas pour se faire
peur en musique et après les nuits de la
lecture la Nuit des Musées visite guidée
libre ou animations les musées yvelinois
vous invite à franchir leur porte pour
redécouvrir leurs collection
gratuitement et depuis plus de 20 ans la
ville d'Andrésy célèbre l'art à travers
son événement sculpture en Lille le
principe des artistes viennent exposer
leurs œuvres contemporaines de Paris à
Andrésy ballon de baudruge cordage ou
encore bois et scotch l'édition 2023
pourraient encore nous surprendre
direction la ville royale le Mois
Molière reviendra cette année pour fêter
le célèbre dramaturge il s'agira de la
27ème édition comédien et compagnie
talentueux seront au rendez-vous avec
des centaines de pièces pour faire deux
Versailles une scène à ciel ouvertes
autre événement incontournable à
Versailles les grandes musicales cet été
vous pourrez encore profiter de la
beauté des jardins de Versailles et des
bosquets exceptionnellement ouverts au
rythme de la musique baroque ne manquez
pas non plus les grandes zones nocturnes
de mi-juin à mi-septembre qui vous
offriront un mémorable feu d'artifice
[Musique]
les Yvelines sont également dotés de
nombreux festivals ont commencé à
Voisins le bretonneux avec de la musique
reggae la tour mêlée tranquille pour une
7e édition si vous êtes plus électro ne
ratez pas le festival électrique Park
sur l'île des Impressionnistes à Chatou
la programmation n'est pas encore
finalisée mais elle promet l'année
dernière Martin Solveig avait enflammé
la scène
[Musique]
que le même mois Poissy HR et le PEC
organise leur festival dédié à la
chanson française et francophone depuis
30 ans des grands noms full la scène
comme Juliette Armanet Véronique Sanson
ou encore Yannick Noah et enfin ce Grand
Chelem se termine sur l'île lomone à
Mantes-la-Jolie les olfactory festival
devrait se tenir pour une cinquième
édition avec trois scènes et plus de 20
concerts l'année dernière ce festival se
distingue par sa programmation
éclectique
du projet et on est de retour en plateau
pour parler de plusieurs choses
culturelles on a parlé des événements à
venir il y a également des choses qui se
passent au niveau culturel dans les
Yvelines on parlait tout à l'heure des
exploits de cast avec vous Margaux
Lallier je rappelle que vous êtes
directrice du pôle médiation action
culturelle et publique au CMBV le CMBV
c'est le Centre de Musique Baroque de
Versailles on disait tout à l'heure on
commença à présenter le concept de ses
exploits qui sont des une expérience
sonore
visuel et le tout digital quel est
l'objectif pourquoi mais un lancer ce
type de support pour le CMBV alors le
Centre de Musique Baroque de Versailles
sa mission c'est de faire rayonner la
musique baroque française des 17e et 18e
siècle donc déjà ça ça pose le cadre
dans lequel on se situe et l'ex podcast
et on dit bien un expatcast c'est un
podcast et une exposition
ça a été conçu en 2020 le format a été
inventé en 2020 pendant le confinement
en réalité puisque les activités
culturelles s'étant arrêtées il a fallu
réfléchir à comment faire perdurer cette
mission du rayonnement de la musique
baroque française et donc les équipes du
CMBV se sont voilà remuer les méninges
et on crée cet objet qui est un espèce
de musée en ligne avec ces expériences
effectivement auditives avec ce podcast
et puis les salles d'exposition
mais aussi tout un tas de choses
à ajouter de des quiz des vidéos de
d'interview avec des spécialistes il y a
plusieurs épisodes mais aussi plusieurs
supports en fait finalement alors un
exploit de typique c'est 5 ou 6 épisodes
qu'on dira tout public et puis depuis le
2e opus déjà sur Molière l'an passé des
épisodes junior à disposition plutôt des
des enfants voilà oui c'est ça il y a
pour tout public et aussi pour le public
plus jeune bon ben écoutez justement un
extrait de l'expot cast numéro 3 qui est
sorti en novembre vous disiez il y a
plusieurs plusieurs formes et notamment
des interviews également avec des
spécialistes et on apprend plein de
choses intéressantes et je vous propose
notamment de d'en savoir un peu plus sur
la naissance de l'opéra comique c'est
Judith Leblanc dramaturge et historienne
qui nous en parle regardez
alors comment est né l'Opéra Comique
puisque les forains n'ont ni le droit de
parler ni le droit de chanter en raison
des interdits qui pèsent sur eux du fait
de ces deux grands théâtres officiels
ils vont inventer dans les années 1710
un tas de subterfuge pour contourner ses
interdits ils vont inventer notamment ce
qu'on pourrait considérer comme
l'ancêtre du karaoké les pièces par
écrit tôt il faut savoir que les
écriteaux descendaient des cintres et
sur ces écritaux étaient écrits sur
l'aire 2 et c'était des veaux de ville
qu'est-ce qu'un veau de ville à l'époque
et bien c'est un air de musique
populaire populaire au sens de connu
d'un grand nombre de personnes sur
lequel on greffe des paroles inédites et
les premiers opéra comiques seront
fondés sur cette dramaturgie musicale
des veaux de ville
les karaoké existaient presque à
l'époque de louisian on apprend des
anecdotes assez croustillantes assez
très intéressantes absolument c'est tout
à fait l'objet de l'expotcasse de
proposer des faits inédits et puis là
effectivement cette explode cast sur la
région ce qui est une période assez peu
connue de l'histoire de la course
c'est-à-dire la période entre la mort de
Louis XIV et la majorité de son fils
Louis XV donc ce régent Philippe
d'Orléans qui est très connu pour avoir
fait la fête on peut parler du film de
Taverny et que la fête commence voilà
c'est vraiment une période de l'histoire
et dont c'est l'anniversaire cette année
c'était aussi on parlait des sujets des
exploscas évidemment on essaye d'avoir
un élément d'actualité donc l'année
dernière sur Molière avec les programmes
du bac 400 ans
de la naissance de Molière absolument et
donc c'est l'occasion de surfer comme on
peut sur les sujets d'actualité malgré
l'ancienneté du sujet et de proposer ce
format assez inédit
l'actualité que ce soit d'un point de
vue sociétal ou même économique
d'ailleurs vous pourrez en apprendre
plus dans l'expotcas la chanteuse d'État
qui est avec nous aussi ça pourrait vous
intéresser vous de découvrir la musique
baroque peut-être que vous connaissez
déjà je connais un petit peu ouais mais
oui ça m'intrigue un peu cette histoire
j'ai bien envie de découvrir les
exploits sont en ligne sur le site
Internet de Radio France Musique sur
l'application et sur toutes les
plateformes de streaming donc il y a
trois numéros déjà qui sont sortis on
attend bien sûr le prochain avec
impatience on va terminer avec vous sur
l'année 2023 qui s'ouvre pour le CMBV le
Centre de Musique Baroque de Versailles
voir un peu les projets les grands
dossiers de cette année il y a aussi un
projet qui a été lancé un grand projet
on peut on peut le dire c'est ville
baroque avec les villes de la verrière
et de Maurepas cette année est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
ce projet nous parler aussi des autres
dossiers un peu chaud en ce début
d'année je peux absolument vous parler
de ce programme ville baroque j'adore le
faire
le programme qui a pris naissance sur un
appel de la Préfecture de Région
Île-de-France pour venir sur ce qu'ils
appellent les jumelage culturels entre
des institutions culturelles et des
villes de la grande couronne donc on
n'est pas les seuls le CMBV n'est pas le
seul à avoir ce type de jumelage il y a
aussi le Louvre Lina enfin voilà le
Centre Pompidou des grandes institutions
culturelles et qui viennent sur le temps
long s'installer dans des territoires et
donc pour le CMBV sur les territoires de
Maurepas et la verrière la verrière ça
fait du sens pour nous puisqu'on y était
déjà sur des précédents projets et donc
c'est aussi la continuité la possibilité
d'apprendre à se connaître d'apprendre à
connaître un territoire et ses habitants
et donc on propose nous proposons le
Centre de musique baroque propose des
activités pour tous les âges de la toute
petite enfance donc de la crèche
jusqu'au seniors et avec la
particularité d'avoir ouvert depuis
septembre de cette année une section
baroque à destination des élèves du
collège Louis Pergaud de Maurepas qui
est une initiative unique en France
puisqu'elle accueille également les
élèves de classe de SEGPA et de classe
ULIS on peut avoir toutes les
informations sur le CMBV sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran vous vouliez
terminé avec une une date pour débuter
l'année 2023 justement au CMBV
absolument nous avons cette semaine une
actualité brûlante puisque l'ensemble la
Palatine dans le conte de le contexte
pardon du programme la baroque qui est
en incubateur de jeunes ensemble ce
produit à la salle Joe Dassin de
Feucherolles ce samedi 7 janvier à 19h
c'est un concert gratuit autour des
musiques italiennes à la cour de France
et à partir de jeudi reprennent les
jeudis musicaux qui sont des concerts
gratuits assurer par la maîtrise du cmvv
donc des enfants chanteurs à la chapelle
du château de Versailles tous les jeudis
à 17h30
sur le site internet du CMBV merci
Margot l'Allier d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle direction directrice du pôle
médiation action culturel et public au
CMBV vers le centre de musique baroque
de Versailles remonter vers téta une
petite pause encore culturelle dans
cette édition depuis septembre trois
établissements de l'académie de
Versailles participent dispositif
raconte moi ta vie ça a été mise en
place par le fond de dotation auteur
solidaire les élèves sont invités à
écrire leur histoire personnelle pour
développer leur confiance et leur esprit
créatif le reportage de Julien Leroy au
lycée Jacques Vaucanson c'est au mur
c'est toujours pour les autres nous on
nous laisse dans notre coin ça rend fou
pourquoi on n'a pas le droit de partir
au ski exprimer son vécu pour mieux se
construire un objectif majeur du
dispositif raconte-moi ta vie créée par
le fond de dotation auteurs solidaire
durant 20 heures d'ateliers ses lycéens
des Mureaux était accompagné d'un
comédien dans l'écriture d'un récit sur
leur propre histoire une façon de gagner
en confiance pour ses élèves parfois
éloignés du monde culturel ils ont des
choses à dire parce que voilà on est
quand même dans des filières très
techniques ou
l'imaginaire n'a pas forcément beaucoup
sa place qui ont des histoires parfois
folles parfois dur parfois drôle j'écris
sur mon parcours au basket je fais du
basket nous avons à parler et j'ai eu un
prix je me suis amélioré jamais
j'amélioré mon communication grâce à lui
des récits du quotidien laissant parfois
place à l'imaginaire une bulle de
liberté dans le contexte formel du lycée
les thèmes d'écriture des anecdotes de
stage ou encore la passion du sport moi
je m'étais inspirer d'un film qui est
sur Netflix qui s'appelle Athéna c'est
un film qui résume trois l'histoire de
trois frères il y en a un qui meurent
après les autres ils vont se venger il y
a un frère qui veut l'appel autre qui
veut la haine et j'essaie de le remixer
après ma façon
de policier à 18h ma vie ils ont un
vocabulaire qui est le leur et qui peut
être très intéressant et qui justement
peut peut être une vraie langue et un
vrai un vrai endroit de création deux
récits de cette classe du lycée Jacques
Vaucanson seront envoyés un comité de
lecture courant janvier
ces textes là derrière sont proposés un
jury qui est sélectionne l'un des deux
et qui va proposer de d'en faire une
soit une chanson soit un podcast soit
une vidéo les élèves pourront ensuite
réaliser l'oeuvre avant une présentation
au public en juin prochain trois
établissements et 99 élèves de
l'académie de Versailles participent à
cette première édition francilienne
oui l'écriture c'est un moyen c'est un
refus à la fois un moyen aussi peut-être
de s'évader Margot l'Allier oui c'est
certain que la culture l'art dans toutes
ses formes accompagnent le parcours des
jeunes et ça on le voit beaucoup dans
nos territoires et puis voilà avec la
musique et je pense que têta pourra en
parler
le texte et la musique ont beaucoup à
faire ensemble l'écriture très
importante
vous êtes originaire de Montfort Lamaury
et en novembre dernier est sorti votre
premier projet solo bornes Toulouse
voilà j'ai essayé de le prononcer avec
un meilleur accent on va écouter tout de
suite un extrait de Burn c'est l'un des
titres justement de cette paix regarder
[Musique]
5 titres dans cette paix on parlait tout
à l'heure de votre style dark pop
électro et c'est vrai qu'on le sent dans
le clip il y a ce côté un peu sombre on
le sent aussi dans la direction
artistique du clip finalement c'est très
c'est très introspectif c'est très
sombre en effet et là ce clip burn ça
raconte toute une scène
d'autodestruction qui commence dans une
voiture puis il y a tout un récit
narratif entre les différentes étapes de
cette auto de destruction entre les
personnes qui la regardent les personnes
qui la commentent les personnes qui se
font leur propre avis et pour au final
en fait
à la fin en fait on se retrouve deux du
point de vue de la personne qui qui fait
ça et en fait on se rend compte de tout
un tas de choses et c'est un clip en
plan séquence réalisé par Tom Josso vous
êtes enterré entouré dans la réalisateur
pardon pour le lapsus pour la petite
erreur vous êtes entouré d'un
réalisateur c'est à dire que dans le
projet thêta il y a toute une dimension
artistique c'est d'associer un
réalisateur vous travaillez aussi avec
un producteur qui est originaire des
Yvelines
un des deux produits soeurs qui a
travaillé sur le P qui s'appelle fine et
ouais qui vient de qui originaire de
plaisir et l'autre c'est Boma et oui en
effet je me suis entourée de en fait dès
le départ avant même avant même de
commencer à produire vraiment les titres
donc je les avais déjà écrit et puis je
m'étais dit il faut ils font tout de
suite je vais tout de suite envie qu'il
y a une dimension visuelle et l'identité
visuelle et artistique donc j'ai voulu
travailler avec avec un réalisateur et
directeur artistique avant même en fait
de vraiment à l'embryon du projet quoi
et donc je lisais votre premier EP en
solo car vous étiez auparavant membre
dans un groupe de rock c'est ça ça
aurait été un peu brutalement au moment
du covid pourquoi pas justement passer
d'une expérience en groupe à une
expérience solo comment est né cette
volonté bah alors du coup ils ont quand
même je me suis retrouvé à vide après ce
après l'arrêt de ce projet je me suis
d'abord posé la question de est-ce que
je ce que je recommence en groupe ou pas
et finalement j'ai fait des tentatives
et puis ça a pas forcément pas forcément
marché comme je voulais et je me suis
peut-être l'occasion de se remettre à
travailler en solo et c'est vrai qu'il y
a des il y a des choses qui sont plus
plus spontanées du coup quand on
travaille tout seul et d'autres aussi
qui viennent qui peuvent qui peuvent
manquer mais je me retrouve plus moi en
tout cas et puis je me retrouve plus
aussi dans cette musique plus pop plus
plus électronique et plus ouais plus
produite que la musique rock mais j'ai
envie de garder sur scène quand même une
énergie rock c'est pour ça qu'il y a un
batteur il y a une harpiste aussi sur
scène qui est aussi sur sur le P donc il
y a de la harpe de la batterie pour ça
c'est pour la scène les états ça fait
penser à l'alphabet grec mais je crois
que le nom de scène vient de d'origine
familiale
mon deuxième prénom enfin c'est fiamet
et c'est aussi le prénom de ma
grand-mère et son surnom à elle quand
elle était petite c'était état donc elle
était plutôt tête mais je dirais
orthographié avec un H donc c'était au
Thor le moyen de lui rendre de lui
rendre hommage alors la sortie de cette
piste en novembre quelle est la suite
quels sont les projets pour cette année
2023 bah là cette année ça va être de le
diffuser le plus possible sur scène donc
on a quelques dates en janvier j'ai été
sélectionnée aux grands Zebrock qui est
un dispositif d'accompagnement et qui
permet de jouer enfin la finalité c'est
de jouer à la Fête de l'Huma donc ça
c'est si ça se passe bien les Yvelines
ou pas en 2023 et ben j'espère ouais
j'espère allez jouer dans le coin donc
j'ai cette date qui sera le 18 janvier
au hangar à Ivry et une autre date dans
le 91 et puis après d'autres dates à
Paris et voilà merci alors il y aura
beaucoup aussi de vidéos qui vont sortir
de captation live et puis de clips il y
a un nouveau clip aussi qui sort en
février et puis quelque chose pour la
fin de la fin de l'année scolaire en
juin
notamment
votre EP born tools je le rappelle est à
écouter sur toutes les plateformes c'est
une petite réaction on a parlé de
musique baroque est-ce que ça pourrait
vous intéresser cet univers qu'est-ce
que comment vous réagissez
ce que je trouve très chouette c'est de
voir que voilà quel que soit
l'esthétique la jeunesse bénéficie de de
programme pour l'émergence on parle de
zébois que voilà nous on travaille avec
des jeunes qui ont probablement ton âge
ou à peine plus âgé et qui sont aussi
dans une forme d'émergence donc je crois
qu'on a nous structures tout à fait à
les accompagner et puis après de la
harpe dans le la Dark pop à la harpe
dans la musique baroque c'est pas très
loin non non il y a qu'un pas merci en
tout cas et on va terminer cette
émission en cuisine
est-ce que vous aimez cuisiner allez ce
sera la dernière question un peu piège
de cette émission est-ce que vous aimez
cuisiner ou vous êtes plutôt enfin vous
préférez qu'on cuisine pour vous
absolument la cuisine beaucoup et
notamment en famille
en tout cas c'est une habitude
maintenant tous les mardis va la
rencontre des chefs cuisiniers du
territoire pour connaître leurs secrets
le but c'est de vous donner des astuces
pour ensuite briller dans votre cuisine
et ce soir c'est le chef
Eric Voiron qui nous ouvre les portes de
son restaurant c'est les terrasses de
Clairefontaine il nous fait découvrir ce
soir la canette en deux services
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle
Eric Boiron je suis chef de cuisine au
terrasses de Clairefontaine aujourd'hui
je vais vous présenter une recette une
canette fermière en deux services
on a la canette qui est comme ça là qui
est bien mise en place on va la boucler
et ensuite on va la ficeler
ensuite on va la mettre en cuisson dans
une poêle ou un récipient qui va au four
nous allons faire une gastrite
[Musique]
on la prend on la met sur un plateau et
on la laisse reposer pendant au moins 20
minutes à température ambiante et bien
au chaud il faut qu'elle soit bien bien
rosé la cuisson parfaite RD bien bien
rosé d'où l'importance de deux cuisson à
les cuisses se mange bien cuites et les
filets de canettes se mangent bien rosé
on a découpé les magrets qu'on va
pouvoir servir tout de suite dans des
assiettes chaudes et les cuisses en
petits morceaux pour faire la salade et
on y met la sauce bien chaude on Flandre
un tout petit peu la sarriette voilà
donc ça c'est pour le premier service
[Musique]
et on fait cuire l'ensemble
il faut compter encore deux trois
minutes à partir du moment où on rajoute
des légumes
[Musique]
et on laisse bien cuire jusqu'à
l'évaporation complète du liquide je
vais rajouter quand même un soupçon de
sel il faut faire attention parce que la
sauce soja sale beaucoup on rajoute un
petit peu de poivre du moulin
les cuisses vont bientôt être prêtes
[Musique]
donc là nous avons réalisé une canette
en deux services les cuisses en salade
et les suprêmes bien bien rosé l'astuce
c'est surtout de bien la laisser reposer
[Musique]
bon on a mis la barre assez haut vous
pourrez quand même la tenter en plateau
cette recette ça vous semble faisable ça
semble faisable en direct sur un plateau
à la télé je sais pas vous avez
peut-être demandé à ce qu'on vous la
fasse cette recette
merci en tout cas encore une fois
d'avoir été avec nous à toutes les deux
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
juste avant de vous laisser on jette un
dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
je vous le disais en début d'édition de
la pluie au menu de votre journée de
mercredi sur l'ensemble du département
demain matin il devrait faire 10 degrés
Rambouillet 11 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles 12 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
l'appui qui sera également de la partie
dans l'après-midi côté température 13
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie aux dents 12
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et ce
mercredi 4 janvier nous faitons les
audilons voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de votre fidélité pour le reste de
la semaine vous avez rendez-vous avec
Mathilde Franco pour de nouvelles
éditions j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver lundi prochain belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]